you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 news now another
chilly evening with those winds still
blowing outside live look outside from
our Strat Camp the high today only 59
degrees that's still below normal 67th
where we should be your morning star now
they're chilly one at 39 the record out
of state 82 degrees here are your
neighborhood's outside we start off in
the far west side of the valley
somewhere at 45 for you 50 even for
Centennial Hills we're 47 for Aliante
the east side coming at 53 just a digit
below that for Green Valley 46 Henderson
44 for you in Southern Highlands and
inspirada outside the valley 47 for
Pahrump 46 up in Mesquite and currently
54 for those of you down in Laughlin the
Breezy winds continue but notice that
Big Ridge still way up to Vancouver
Canada keeping things dry and clear for
the Pacific Northwest same for here
those winds however will continue for
tomorrow we could see that on your
accurate wind forecast not so much to
the southern valleys overnight in the
morning but those Northern neighbor
let's notice that still look at those
double digit wind speeds and then Valley
Wide tomorrow for your Wednesday and
then they'll start to relax a little
more by later on in the afternoon and
the evening hours and Thursday looks a
lot calmer but Friday winds will be back
again next disturbance rolls on in look
at that Breezy winds back again Friday
and also Saturday and they'll back off
by the time we get to Sunday and early
on next week just before Thanksgiving
overnight lows will be chilly again high
30s throughout most of the valley 40 for
downtown no 37 for someone 38 for Anthem
will be in the high 30s for Aliante and
Centennial Hills as well outside of town
Chile up in Mesquite at 35 safer Prim
Death Valley you'll have a low of 47
overnight so here's your forecast 41 to
low Breezy and chilly still overnight
tomorrow your high 59 Breezy and sunny
and that still of course is cooler than
normal should be at 67 degrees your most
accurate eight day forecast here you go
lots of sunshine however those
temperatures hovering around the high
50s we'll be reaching the low 60s on
Saturday but get this finally the mid
60s by the time we get to
pre-thanksgiving for Wednesday next week
that's your most accurate forecast back
over to you all right